I remember seeing Vince I was in the
stands as a young kid my favorite player
we're in the full purple and gold the
shoes and everything full everything
you're vinced out fenced out headband
not even neat I didn't like wearing
Heavens but I wore it just because of
Vince
um and I yelled his name as as
um
as hard as I could
and I said this Carter
and I could tell like he's in the game
like he's in the game and he's got this
kid out of nowhere just heckling at him
and I'm just sitting there so excited
I'm asked can I yell his name can I yell
his name
and he looked up and he went like this
and I'll never forget about that
remember the story remember the day just
just going like just going like that so
when I see a kid or I see a fan I just
drop everything you know I don't have to
carry that with me when I see a kid
um so happy because that that moment
changed my life that moment changed my
outlook my
um perception on people uh all that
stuff so just by when I was six years
old I remember that that changed me